[Music]
we're back
now to the sunshine state where florida
man strikes again
police are asking for your help to find
this so-called freestyling felon
police in port st lucie want to speak to
sean gazzo and carl jackson
they say the pair were hired by an 86
year old to move heavy furniture
but stole ten thousand dollars worth of
jewelry they're accused of pawning the
jewelry
and that's when police say gaza
celebrated a bit prematurely
detectives say gaza can be seen here on
surveillance video outside the pawn shop
dancing in the parking lot gazo and
jackson are wanted for dealing in stolen
property and theft
gigi i'm looking at this as a defense
attorney can you imagine the lineup
video in this case
the officer comes on uh number four can
you dance for me please
uh yes officer that that's the man right
there
what did you make of this smooth
criminal video
well you know what this smooth criminal
he may be a smooth criminal but he's
definitely
bad not michael jackson bad just bad bad
and let me tell you st lucia does not
play with your defendants they throw the
book at them so
if this judge catches a glimpse of this
defendant's moves uh she's sure to throw
the book
at him too because they were not pretty
yeah and it looks like it could be id
quality video from
inside uh the pawn shop but of course i
don't think anyone's going to mistake
those dance moves ever again gigi thank
you very much